this young Starlet is on a path to super
stardom but did you know that it All
Began on Facebook from her role as a
Disney darling to her powerful political
activism and stunning performance as
Wednesday Adams this Unstoppable Rising
Star seems to do it all
for Jenna Ortega the journey to stardom
began with a single movie that captured
Her Imagination like nothing else the
inspiration came at the age of six when
she watched a movie that isn't really
appropriate for six-year-olds in an
interview with collider Ortega revealed
that as a child she joined her older
sister to watch Man on Fire a 2004
Thriller directed by Tony Scott that
stars Denzel Washington as a former CIA
agent turned bodyguard who rescues the
nine-year-old daughter of a businessman
played by Dakota Fanning Ortega added
that it was after watching Fanning who
as she put it was so talented at such a
young age that the budding actress
decided she wanted to be in her words
the Puerto Rican version of Fanning it's
safe to say that Ortega has continued
along the successful professional path
forged by Fanning who went from a rising
child artist to A renowned actress as an
adult Ortega revealed to interview
magazine with her Wednesday co-star
Christina Ricci that in addition to
deciding to perform in front of the
camera she believes that acting would
enable her to realize other Ambitions
she had like becoming the first female
male president or becoming an astronaut
discovering her aspiration as an actor
wasn't enough for Ortega as she also had
to convince her mother Natalie that she
would do okay in that profession Ortega
talked with Latina Magazine about how
she was discovered with the help of the
internet I started begging my mom to let
me act when I was six years old two
years later when I still wanted to do it
she started taking it more seriously
Facebook helped me get my first agent my
mom posted a video of me doing a
dramatic monologue and a friend of hers
from high school forwarded it to an
agent three months later I got my first
audition and the rest is history when
Tamron Hall asked Ortega in 2021 about
whether she remembered her mother
telling her she was going to upload the
video online Ortega answered no I didn't
because she didn't mean anything by it
it was kind of a joke I remember at the
time she didn't want me to be an actor
she just wasn't sure about putting me in
that environment in this industry that
she had heard such terrible things about
she continued saying she posted it just
as a joke for her inside friends because
you know her friends on Facebook knew
that I was very dramatic as is typical
for for up-and-coming actors who are
generating buzz in the industry there
have been rumors that Jenna Ortega might
be joining the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in the new Disney plus series Daredevil
Born Again scheduled for 2024. according
to Giant freaking robot she might even
be playing the role of a new hero named
white tiger in the Marvel Comics white
tiger is a mantle currently helmed by
Ava Ayala who yields an amulet that
grants its users superhuman strength and
Agility keep in mind these rumors are
unconfirmed but the prospect of Ortega
playing a superhero is undeniably
exciting while this may be the actor's
first stint as a superhero most fans
forget that Ortega has already made an
appearance in the MCU in 2013's Iron Man
3 which was the actress's first film
Credit in a very minor role as the vice
president's daughter given that the vice
president's own daughter is an amputee
it is revealed in the film that he is
backing Aldrich Killian's experimental
extremist program which seeks to repair
any debilitating disability by growing
any missing or lost limbs in its host
despite her blink and misappearance in
the film her character represents the
personal motivations for everyone who
supports the extra mess project despite
all of its serious flaws including
high-ranking government officials whose
support gives Killian a lot of political
Leverage
after playing a few supporting roles in
shows like Jane the Virgin and Richie
Rich Ortega finally got her big break as
Harley Diaz in Stuck in the Middle a
Disney Channel sitcom that aired for
three seasons between 2016 and 2018. as
you might have guessed from the show's
title Harley is a fourth wall-breaking
aspiring engineer who is stuck as the
middle child among seven kids
yep that's my mom squatting on a can of
corn in the closet
when you have seven kids and want some
peace this is what happens it was
relatively easier for Ortega to slip
into the shoes of the character since
she herself is a middle child with five
siblings and could draw from her own
personal experiences when portraying the
character the actress told Latina
Magazine playing Harley Diaz is awesome
because I relate to her a lot it is like
I am playing myself we both are middle
children in a big family we both can be
goofballs we both love our families and
we both love math and science the
similarities also enabled Ortega to
contribute ideas to the scripts of each
episode of the show she would illustrate
to the writing team how her own family
would deal with particular situations in
their home which in turn informed how
the show's fictional Diaz family would
deal with the everyday chaos as reported
by Mama's mission
off-screen Ortega has been a vocal
supporter of minority groups and a
staunch advocate of the value of
diversity in the film and television
industry in 2018 Ortega wore a jacket to
the Radio Disney Music Awards with the
quote I do care and you should too
etched on the back this was in reaction
to Melania Trump the then first lady who
wore a jacket with the words I really
don't care do you print it on it during
a visit to a facility housing
undocumented children who had been
separated from their parents the actress
stated there is no excuse to not speak
up it doesn't matter if you have five
followers or a million followers it
doesn't matter your age or where you
come from every voice is important in
addition to her support for the Pro
lgbtq Plus Pride over Prejudice campaign
Ortega's activism also reflects in the
parts she picks for herself refusing
roles that are detrimental to the latinx
community she explained to Cosmopolitan
I feel like the latinx Community First
of all they're not often shown on camera
in general but they're also oftentimes
not shown in a positive light I never
want to play a maid and I never want to
play a cartel leader daughter I would
much rather play a person of power a
powerful character in a positive way
given that an actor's physical
appearance continuously draws attention
and plays a role in their career working
as an actor in the film and television
industry can be brutal for one's
self-image or take a revealed to People
magazine that she had gone through a
similar ordeal recalling a negative
experience when she was made to feel
shameful about her freckles when she was
a teenager I think any insecurity that I
had with my skin was more in terms of
working with makeup artists I remember
one once made a comment about not being
able to match my skin tone correctly and
that they needed to cover things up for
a while I was really ashamed of my
freckles and didn't want to show my face
ever I'd get comments like oh you have a
dirty face as a result Ortega decided to
endorse a message of positivity and the
beauty of uniqueness after becoming the
brand ambassador of the Skin Care brand
Neutrogena in 2020. whose products
Ortega claims to have been using for
most of her life she went on to describe
her consistent skincare routine using a
variety of Neutrogena products she
concluded by highlighting how important
influencer diversity visibility and
brand messaging are as well as how her
vision aligns with the Brand's mission
to spread a message that's about
embracing natural beauty in addition to
being an actor philanthropist activist
and brand ambassador Ortega has proven
herself as a talented author having
published her first book in 2021 it's
all love Reflections for your heart and
soul is a non-fiction self-help book
filled with quotes and anecdotes penned
by Ortega herself that aims to help its
readers mainly teenagers deal with their
mental health difficulties or take a
discussed the book with j14 saying it's
all love is a collection of stories and
lessons I've experienced while growing
up in a non-traditional sense I think a
lot of what I've been through might be
helpful or insightful for teens
struggling with their identity the first
time authors cited her own struggles
with mental health saying I've never
addressed my aggressive struggle with my
mental health and I talk about that
somewhere in this book it's weird I'm
not a very social person but I also want
to be as sincere as possible in all I do
and I think it might be nice for those
who also have a hard time to know that
they're not alone Ortega reaffirmed the
purpose of writing the book by saying
being a teenager is tough if there's
anything I can do just to be a source of
comfort or helpful in any way it would
bring me immense Joy people have been so
kind towards me and I want to return the
favor
if my family was a week I'd be Wednesday
Ortega found that playing Wednesday
Adams comes with its own expectations
and difficulties when you think about it
it makes sense the character's been
ingrained in the cultural Zeitgeist for
nearly 60 years ever since she made her
on-screen debut in the 1964 sitcom The
Addams Family Jenna Ortega had to study
fencing archery canoeing cello and
German in order to match the multiple
talents demonstrated by her character on
screen for the 2022 Netflix series
additionally Ortega face the creative
obstacles of working with multiple
directors on the series each of whom had
their own Visions for her character she
explained to Wednesday co-star Christina
Ricci we were going from Tim Burton to
another director back to Tim to another
director I felt like everybody wanted
different things from her there were a
lot of battles like that because I felt
like people didn't always trust me when
I was creating my path in terms of okay
this is her Arc this is where she gets
emotional Ortega added I would call my
parents every night in a panic because I
felt like it was different from any job
I had ever done before I got out to
Romania and we started training and
shooting immediately we didn't really
have time for rehearsals I remember it
being very stressful and confusing I did
the best I could but that's probably the
most overwhelming job I've ever had
aside from reprising her role as Tara
Carpenter and scream 6 and Wednesday
Adams in the sophomore season of
Netflix's Wednesday Ortega is set to
Star alongside film Legend Tommy Lee
Jones in the upcoming Paramount plus
Thriller film finest kind and Martin
Freeman in lionsgate's Miller's girl her
foray and two off-screen Endeavors with
her advocacy and writing demonstrates
that her Ambitions extend beyond acting
in a 2016 interview with Latina Magazine
when she was 14 at the time Ortega
discussed her future goals saying I
would really like to get some lead roles
in big feature films in the near future
when I grow up I would like to get into
directing writing producing amp still
act true to her word the actress is
slated to make her debut as an executive
producer on the romantic drama winter
spring summer or fall in which she will
also star with her Wednesday Pier Percy
Hines white in a 2021 interview with
Cosmopolitan or spoke about embracing
her past as a Disney kid and her hopes
to act in independent films and passion
projects saying I do want to do projects
that challenge me a little bit more and
put me in situations that I may not
necessarily be able to initially relate
to just to push myself and see what I
can do
[Music]
foreign